-Well, hey, how about this one?
Regarding my panic attacks,
I've had more psychotic episodes
than "Twin Peaks."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I'm so crazy...
-How crazy are you?
-There we go.
[ Laughter ]
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Jason Sudeikis.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a clip from the third
season of "Ted Lasso."
We talked about this
in the past.
You've been on the show
with Joe Kelly, Brendan Hunt.
I've known all you guys
for over two decades.
We worked together in Amsterdam.
One of the things we spent time
doing was playing FIFA.
-Yeah.
-And, I mean, I never would have
predicted this.
You are now a character in FIFA.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, yeah.
It's --
Again, and this is nice.
Otis will play FIFA.
This was a big deal
to everybody in the cast.
But we -- whenever Otis sees
that, he goes, "Why --
It looks like you,
but you're so mad."
[ Laughter ]
And as a dad, I was like,
"He doesn't view me that way,"
which I thought was so nice.
I was like --
You know what I mean?
'Cause you're always like,
"Don't do that!
Put that down!"
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-No, he's like, "No, this is
a guy who's very upset
at his defensive team."
His defense --
And it's very different
from the "Ted Lasso" character.
But I think, you know,
they just --
-Whereas, when my son
sees this show, he's like,
"Why are you so happy?"
[ Laughter ]
-"Why are you talking so much?"
"Why are you so interested
in these other people's --
these stranger's jobs?"
-"Yeah, why not
just let them be?"
-"You don't watch
any of this stuff.
You say you like all of it.
You sit in your office
and do nothing."
-"Is there ever gonna be a
'Closer Look' about me, Dad?"
-"Take a closer look here,
papa!"
[ Laughter ]
They don't get it.
It's like, "Oh, yeah?
You go buy your own food,
you little son of a --"
[ Laughter ]
-Talk to my wife.
If I have a catchphrase at home,
it's, "You go buy your own food,
you son of a --"
[ Laughter ]
-The Great Santini.
Lines that got cut.
-[ Laughs ]
-But, yeah, this thing meant
more to any of the fellas
that we were looking at
on this show
that play on the cast.
They get to be on that game.
They've been playing it
for as long as we have.
But since they were little kids,
even.
And, like, two Emmy's --
la-de-da.
To be an actual player on there,
yeah, was, like,
I think it helped relationships
with their fathers, you know?
[ Laughter ]
That were like,
"I'm going to be an artist,
Dad."
And they were like, "You go
buy your own food, you --"
[ Laughter ]
It's like,
"Dad, I'm a footballer.
I'm a real fake footballer."
[ Laughter ]
-Now, have you noticed this?
Because I will say,
a couple years ago,
much like any athlete
who hangs it up,
because I played FIFA
for like 20 straight years.
I realized
I just don't have it anymore.
-Yeah.
-You know, at some point,
you just lose the touch.
-Yeah, yeah.
No, mine's gotten better,
weirdly, because I understand
the game a tad bit better
from just hanging out
with Brendan
and going to see matches.
-Yeah.
-We try to go, like,
every week to something.
And this last season was great.
Season, two we didn't get
to do much because everybody
was still on lockdown.
But by this point in the show,
it was so well-received
that people were like,
"Come watch, come watch."
And so we'd go.
And then I'm kind of like,
"Okay, I think I understand
what's going on here."
And then, when playing with
our own players, I was like,
"Well, I know
what their skills are."
You know,
"This guy hits his mark.
He shows up late."
[ Laughter ]
You know, "He improvises well."
But, it's -- I've gotten
a little bit better.
You know, oddly.
-Oh, good.
-And I think, you know,
are you playing games
with your kids yet?
-Not yet.
-Yeah.
That's -- That's where, I think,
it's gonna get tricky
because I know he will
soon overpass me.
-Right.
That's gonna be tough.
-Yeah, yeah, that's gonna be --
that's not gonna be
on a driveway, though,
where I get hurt.
It's just gonna be my ego.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"You go buy
your own controllers."
[ Laughter ]
-Do you -- have the kids
discovered any of your
"SNL" work from the past?
-Yeah.
-They have?
-Literally in the past couple --
in the past month.
And they've asked.
They've asked.
I remember showing them some --
or I think they watched
when I hosted October --
two Octobers ago.
And then, when you get into,
you know, the YouTube algorithm,
then they just start showing up
on the side,
and they want to watch them.
And we watched
some of the best ones --
I did this sketch.
You'll know.
You probably won't.
"Maine Justice."
-"Maine Justice," classic.
[ Cheers ]
I think we have a photo
of "Maine Justice."
Maine Justice, here you are
with Jamie Foxx.
Did they follow "Maine Justice"?
-No. No one does.
-No one does,
I was gonna say.
-You and Lorne were very picky
about wanting context and logic.
-I would like to concede
the point now that I was wrong.
You know?
-That's very, very big of you.
-I had a lot of questions
about the logic
behind "Maine Justice,"
and then you did it
for the audience, and I'm like,
"They don't care."
-They don't care.
[ Laughter ]
And yet I'm logic cop
on our show.
So I've taken it elsewhere
and driven people crazy.
-I feel bad -- I do feel bad
because after this crushed
during that commercial break,
I went out
and I yelled at the audience.
I'm like,
"I tried to stand up for you!"
[ Laughter ]
"And it turns out you didn't
care about any of it!"
-I remember in my office, like,
O'Brien -- and Mike O'Brien
was my office mate and defending
that when Lorne would be like,
"What's the logic here?"
and it's like,
"Man, you gave us
Toonces the Driving Cat, dude.
You forged this."
-Yeah.
"You made this idiocy.
Like, what was the logic there,
man?"
No.
-"Maine Justice."
-"Maine Justice,"
and then Potato Chip
is literally the same character
[Cajun accent]
where I sorta talk like this.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] And so,
Otis was doing the voice, like,
a few days later.
I'm just doing George Kennedy
from "Cool Hand Luke."
I'm doing like Foghorn Leghorn.
And when you hear your little
8 1/2-year-Old son do it,
it sounds problematic.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Because I'm like, well --
I'm like, "What are you doing?
What are you --"
And then I realize,
"Oh, he's doing Maine Justice."
He's doing that.
-That's a tricky thing
when the principal calls
and says, "Your son,
he's telling us he's doing
'Maine Justice.'"
-Yeah, exactly!
-"And our question for you is,
what's the logic?"
-Exactly!
[ Laughter ]
You know, and that's an L.A.
school for you.
Everybody's in the business.
A lot of studio execs.
[ Laughter ]
That's their fallback career
is principals.
But I --
[ Laughter ]
But then they've -- "A-Holes,"
Kristen Wiig and I did.
-Gotcha.
I mean, 9 and 6.
Do they know
what A-hole stands for?
-Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I told them apathy.
-Apathy's pretty on the money
for the A-holes.
-Yeah, and they're like,
"Oh, you mean the anus?"
I go, "How did you
put that together?"
No, they didn't really.
[ Laughter ]
And then, last week,
I showed them Roundball Rock,
which was a sketch
that Tim Robinson
and I believe Zach Cannon wrote.
-Uh-huh.
-Where we played John Tesh --
-And Dave Tesh.
-And he plays his brother,
Dave Tesh.
-Roundball Rock.
[ Laughter ]
This is great.
And this is great.
Tim now "I Think
You Should Leave" fame.
-Yeah, yeah.
Emmy Award winner.
-Emmy Award winner.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And fantastic dude, all around.
And this is a great one.
So, your kids like that one,
as well?
-Yes. And they sing the song --
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-basketball.
It's like, there's just lyrics.
Dave Tesh wrote lyrics to
John Tesh's instrumental,
like, famous --
♪ Dun dun dun dun dun, da da ♪
and it's just him going
♪ Ba-ba-ba-ba-basketball ♪
♪ Gimme gimme gimme the ball
'cause I'm gonna dunk it ♪
Yeah, and just repeats it
over and over.
So I just hear Otis and Daisy
getting ready in the morning.
♪ Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-basketball ♪
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "We're doing it.
We're doing God's work."
-And is it true from A-holes
that they only do you?
-They only do me, yeah.
Like, yeah,
'cause it's the easier part
to play. Right?
Kristen's bringing nuance to it.
I'm just, like, a belligerent,
like, gum-chomping A-hole.
Right?
But, yeah.
They're just like,
"Hey babe, hey, babe."
Just doing the whole thing.
And it's like, love it.
-We -- I met my wife Alexi,
you know, during --
it was during the A-hole years
of "SNL."
And we just started
ironically calling each other
"babe" like that sketch.
Terrible mistake 'cause it
[bleep] stuck.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-And now, like, here it is,
whatever, 15 years later,
and I'm walking around
in front of my kids, like,
without irony now, being like,
"Hey, babe, hey, babe."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "How did this happen?"
Be careful.
-I know.
We tapped into something there.
As long as you're saying
please and thank you,
no one's gonna call you A-holes.
That was just two people
being really mean to people
that were trying to help.
-Yep, that was the core of it.
-And they loved each other.
-They did love each other.
-He loved her.
He loved --
Jason's character
loved Kristen's character.
But A-holes
to the rest of the world.
-There you go.
Hey, man, congratulations
on another great season.
-Thank you.
-It's so lovely
to have you back here.
-Great to be back.
-Really appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jason Sudeikis.
Third season, "Ted Lasso,"
streaming on apple TV+.
New episodes on Wednesdays.
We'll be right back with
Annaleigh Ashford.